boa noite boa noite a todos
sou irmão áreas como bem foi dito né na
minha certidão de nascimento diz que o
nice se há 26 anos em 1991 mas eu não
sei exatamente dois anos vai completar
agora dia 19 deste mês
foi quando eu fui mãe pela primeira vez
né eu tinha um sonho enorme da
maternidade e eu já tinha conseguido é
várias várias coisas na minha vida que
eu havia almejado né passei vestibular
fiz o curso que eu queria é casey diz
casey é trabalhar empresas que eu
almejava conquistei é status financeiro
tinha tudo mas eu não tinha maternidade
que era o meu maior desejo
então recebi de diagnósticos de 4
obstetras que eu não poderia ser mãe
então quando eu já estava desistindo
dessa dessa a parte que me faltava é de
repente eu me encontro enjoada e grávida
né com isso o fla maior felicidade da
minha vida compensação é eu engravidei
do guilherme
no ano da crise e no ano da zica né eu
posso porque eu levei tanto tempo né pra
para engravidar eu queria tanto porque
veio justamente esse ano e muitas vezes
a gente julga reclama sem saber o que
vem pela frente sem saber do amanhã né e
passou foi uma gravidez muito tranquila
neodi descobrir a patologia do guilherme
no nascimento
então eu acho que o susto é maior quando
a gente descobre que aquele filho que
você idealizou não é morreu nem vai ver
uma outra criança de um modo diferente
né é como a gente planeja uma viagem
planeja uma viagem daqui pro rio de
janeiro então a gente vai planejando
néca os meses se aproximando a gente
planeja os lugares que vai visitar nem
as comidas que vai experimentar pontos
turísticos tudo isso então de repente
você embarca no avião
o avião decola quando está cheio
randon no seu destino era uma aeromoça
diz a bem-vinda o maranhão é o senhor
planeja uma viagem para o rio de janeiro
que estou fazendo no maranhão
não que o maranhão seja menos feio mas
não é o rio de janeiro não era aquilo
que você está planejando então com isso
você tem que se adaptar àquela situação
aquele lugar né então foi assim chegou
um filho que é a coisa que eu mais
desejava no mundo o primeiro neto
primeiro sobrinho o primeiro filho tudo
e foi entregue um filho que você não
planeja um filho diferente né e você
tinha que andar com aquela criança e
todas as necessidades que ela trazia né
mas o que foi que eu fiz uma tentativa
de me defender de defender a minha
família eu escondi a patologia do
guilherme né eu conversei com o pai dele
e disse olha como a gente descobriu
nascimento ele passou por vários exames
e lá confirmou até então ninguém sabia
exatamente o que estava acontecendo todo
mundo todo o mundo foi pego de surpresa
por esse surto e ninguém sabia o que
estava acontecendo da onda que vinham
que poderia causar né as consequências
então a gente vai fazer o seguinte com
meu filho ele veio esteticamente
perfeito e não tem aquela má formação
ucraniana que visivelmente você
identifica a patologia em outras
crianças é eu poderia foi a escapatória
saída para me esconder
então eu resolvi com o pai dele que
iríamos sair da além do hospital depois
de nove dias de internamento né na
investigação e não iremos contar a
ninguém
até aí tudo bem né eu não podia ver um
jornalista que eu corria pra trás dele
para não aparecer porque ninguém podia
me ver com o meu filho naquela situação
então aos poucos eu fui conhecendo
outras famílias fui conhecendo outras
pessoas que estavam na mesma situação
que eu e eu fui me identificando o
seguinte eu gente que está acontecendo
porque eu estou me escondendo quer que
há de mal nisso porque elas não estão se
escondendo por que é o estou como é que
eu posso exigir um mundo melhor para o
meu filho se eu sou a primeira não dá a
cara a tapa pra fazer aquele
o melhor né então é com isso se passaram
três meses nesses três meses foi um
aprendizado imenso foi vítima de
inúmeros preconceitos na sociedade
aquele olhar de pena aquele olhar de
coitadismo aquele em essien mata
qualquer mãe sabe por que você enxerga
seu filho tão perfeito sabe ele é tão
filho então as pessoas enxergam nele um
modo diferente então com isso machuca só
me machucava
então eu vi a força de outras mães de
outras famílias hoje eu não eu preciso
ser igual a elas né e então foi aí
quando eu comecei a trabalhar isso
dentro de mim e identificar que aquele
era um monstro que me consumia por
dentro sabe e era o preconceito
então quando existe aquela frase que a
gente primeiro precisa mudar a gente
para depois tentar mudar o outro e o
mundo não é mentira que às vezes a gente
hipócrita a gente exige do outro aquilo
que nem a gente mesmo tá nem a gente
mesmo oferece né e então eu precisava
trabalhar aquilo dentro de mim trabalhar
aquilo dentro da minha casa
dentro da minha família para depois
poder ajudar outras pessoas a superarem
inicialmente aquele quando digo superar
esperar de verdade é superar o molde que
quando alguém falar com você não doer
sabe alguém agir da mesma forma com
aquele mesmo preconceito com você não
machucar sabe é você tentar mostrar para
aquela pessoa que não é aquela visão não
é aquilo que ela tá enxergando é aquilo
que que não é aquele conceito que ela
tem
então aí começou a minha história né
comecei a trabalhar isso dentro de mim
trabalhei isso na época com o meu marido
e trabalhar isso dentro da minha família
que é aí onde dói mais né porque quando
vem do outro ainda a tudo bem mas quando
vem de dentro de casa da nossa própria
carne dói e dói muito
sáb ao não aceito ele não tem nada meu
neto não tem nada meu sobrinho não tem
nada e você sabendo que existe todo lá
uma coisa nem eu posso não me acorda de
madrugada pra em hospitais se ele não
tivesse nada
né ea gente às vezes alimenta a
esperança uma falsa esperança de que
realmente não teria nada mas sempre
surge algo novo que me fazia entender
que ele tinha né então assim o porquê
meu filho ele vai ser menos amado ele
vai ser menos cidadão porque ele tem uma
limitação porque ele tem uma patologia
ele não pediu para nascer assim eu não
pedi para ele assim e eu não vou lutar
por ele não vai ser meu filho por conta
disso então quer dizer que você é uma
pessoa com deficiência é algo inferior a
outras pessoas é algo que que diminui
meu filho diminui a mim como mulher como
mãe quer dizer que eu sou - mãe do que
uma outra mãe que tem um filho na mesma
idade que eu mas ele não tem deficiência
fez não isso vai mudar né e mudou
com isso o terceiro mês e reúne toda a
minha família reunir todos os meus
amigos e contei gente foi uma hora e 40
minutos eu contando desde o dia que o
médico me deu o diagnóstico não podia
engravidar até o dia que eu descobri a
patologia do guilherme e todo mundo lá
tem escutado porque ninguém esperava ea
única coisa que eu pedi a todos foi o
seguinte não venham com pena com
preconceito para a nossa família porque
a gente não quer a gente não merece
só queremos o seu respeito é então assim
a gente teve um apoio muito grande um
apoio muito forte dos nossos amigos e
daí começou a minha missão né primeiro e
identifiquei o que me causava mau
trabalhei
superei ao ponto de não doer mais pode
chegar a qualquer pessoa com qualquer
atitude não vai doer mais eu vou tentar
trabalhar naquela pessoa né ela não está
procedendo da maneira correta né às
vezes a pessoa acha que ele é doente
pequim não mas não é doente ele tinha
uma patologia ele não vai conseguir
fazer é coisas que outras crianças da
faixa etária dele vão conseguir
normalmente ele vai demorar um tempo
maior tudo no seu tempo mas não é doente
tem mais saúde do que eu inclusive né
então assim é normal é normal
ao ele possui dois olhos uma boca nariz
é super normal não tem diferença né
então foi aí que eu comecei a enxergar
como a sociedade enxerga a pessoa com
deficiência né então com isso em meio à
dor em meio ao sofrimento em meio a
inúmeros diagnósticos negativos em meio
a um futuro incerto
eu resolvi transformar aquela dor
encorajem aquela doença superação para
enfrentar todos os obstáculos que eu
iria encontrar um dia a dia porque dali
eu percebi que não seria fácil não seria
fácil quando a gente recebe um
diagnóstico negativo não é fácil quando
a gente recebe preconceito de dentro de
casa e fora de casa não é fácil quando
você não tem seus direitos adquiridos
existe direito muito papel em lei mas na
prática é difícil iria encontrar
dificuldade quando eu resolvi fazer uma
união de mães um coletivo de mães que
viviam e vivem a mesma realidade que eu
estava vivendo para poder lutar não vão
melhorar só que isso aqui nunca bom
então a gente identificou que vivíamos
os as mesmas lacunas e a gente queria
mudança porque é direito né então assim
a gente fez
fundei sou presidente estou como
presidente fundadora da ong união de
mães de anjos com a associação que cuida
acolhe de mães e famílias de bebês com a
minha raça faria que no o termo correto
é a síndrome congênita da música vírus
né e hoje há uma cole 399 bebês em todo
o estado dá de recife até o sertão
inclusive hoje tivemos três eventos
acontecendo ao mesmo tempo recife
caruaru e ouricuri ea gente chegou de
caruaru naquela correria mas deu tudo
certo ea gente coordenando tentando
coordenar tudo isso e a partir da uma
dessa associação dessa ong
eu passei a ajudar outras famílias
outras pessoas né desde a aceitação
porque imagina você tem um filho e você
não aceitá lo
é a coisa mais triste do mundo sabe
então você poderá ajudar uma mãe uma
família a aceitar aquilo que deus te deu
a entender que você foi uma privilegiada
no não enxergue a si mesmo como a
sociedade enxerga que você é a mulher
menos privilegiada por ter um filho com
deficiência não você é uma mulher de
muita sorte você é um pai de muita sorte
porque deus ele confiou a você
a missão de cuidar de um anjo isso não é
pra qualquer um
se não é para todas as pessoas deus ele
não dá pessoas que não são capacitadas
ele não dá às pessoas que não iam
conseguir carregar a dor carregar os
inúmeros nãos que recebemos no dia a dia
sabe e mesmo assim ser mãe
76 8% das mulheres que são acolhidas
pela uma é eu não estou vendo o tempo
correr aqui tal gente então é óbvio não
está não está correndo aqui pra mim é 71
minutos e 86 por cento das mulheres que
são acolhidas pela uma delas são
abandonadas pelo seu companheiro porque
o homem ele não suporta o peso que a
mulher suporta eu sou estatística estou
acompanhado aqui jaqueline vieira a mãe
de daniel secretária da oma ela
estatística sabe então essa mãe
essa mulher precisa ser mãe pai
cuidadora 24 horas fisioterapeuta
fonoaudiólogo terapeuta ocupacional
psicóloga chefe de família sabe e ela
precisa andar linda de salto alto
maquiada sabe perfeita e não é assim
somos mulheres reais
então a gente aprendeu na dor da
realidade o que essa operação o que é
você poder sentir a dor de perto o
sofrimento de perto a rejeição e
desprezo da vida e entender que aquilo
daria uma coisa boa é que você pode
tirar de tudo aquela realidade em coisas
boas coisas que trazem pra você e eu
digo com toda a certeza do mundo e falo
aqui representando mais de 400 milhões
em todo o estado de pernambuco que
depois do nascimento do meu filho foi a
melhor coisa do mundo da minha vida eu
melhorei como ser humano eu sou a pessoa
mais simpática eu me coloco no lugar do
próximo
eu sou uma pessoa que eu tive o prazer
de ajudar o próximo e quando a gente
ajuda o próximo a gente é ajudado então
além da gente lutar por direitos
é a gente trabalha a inclusão ea
inclusão nada mais é do que o respeito
que é isso que eu trago para vocês
quando a gente respeita o próximo
a gente tá respeitando assim e respeitar
e cuidando de nós e dos nossos
descendentes
então prática a inclusão pra ter um
respeito
pratique um amor e se sim depararem com
a situação difícil na vida entenda
da mesma forma que não chegou ao fim do
túnel para você né assim a gente entende
também hoje o nosso lema é que a
microsafe faria não é o fim a gente
declara isso aos quatro cantos do mundo
e eu sou muito feliz pela oportunidade
de compartilhar isso com todos vocês
muito obrigado e boa noite
[Aplausos]